bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur arte france alors que s'est-il passé
avec la police lors de la manifestation
à rennes
bonjour alors tout d'abord c'est ce
n'était pas à rennes c'était à la même
manifestation de paris où j'étais
présent voilà donc vous avez entendu le
l'énoncé de revendications de la
confédération paysanne
c'est ce que nous nous défendons dans
nos hémicycle au parlement donc c'est la
raison pour laquelle je me suis déplacé
là bas en soutien et aussi en
intermédiaires pour calmer le jeu parce
qu'il y avait 2,2 de la violence latente
alors que la manifestation était non
violente et petit parce qu'il y avait
200 personnes à tout casser mais
déterminée pour ne pas bouger parce
qu'ils veulent se faire entendre et tant
qu'il n'avait pas une une réponse pour
un rendez vous il restait là voilà alors
un moment j'étais isolé avec les
journalistes avec interdiction de
rejoindre la manifestation
j'ai montré ma carte en disant que
j'étais sénateur et que vous pouvez pas
m'empêcher de circuler pour aller
prendre la parole seck est fermée à un
moment un des policiers après son pied
m'a bousculée violemment avec son avec
son bouclier donc dassin je me suis
défendu j'ai pris son bouclier gelé
février voilà c'était l'incident a été
clos sauf que par rapport à mon droit
d'expression parlementaire eh bien il a
été interdit par là par la police donc
je suis très amer de cela et j'ai vu les
images au sujet de ma collègue député de
l'ariège et elle a été violemment poussé
dans le dos qui l'a fait tomber
on voit les images un qui passe à côté
d'où ça veut dire qu'on vous a empêché
de prendre le micro vous n'avez pas pris
la parole lors de la manifestation à
paris à la fin de la manifestation non
je l'avais prise au tout début mais
après les négociations de 2,2 rendez
vous puisque j'avais appelé moi-même
l'elysée pour les mettre en relation
après une fois que les manifestants ont
été encadrés par la police on nous
encadrer nos ainsi avec les journalistes
avec interdiction pour nous les paroles
les parlementaires de retourner parlé
aux manifestants qui étaient toujours au
retour au pacifisme et mon propos devait
être pacifique également
alors vous avez donc rejoindre les
agriculteurs qui a manifesté sa veut
dire que vous comprenez leur malaise je
comprends et je le défends et je vois la
différence de traitement lorsqu'il y a
des grosses manifestations à l'appel de
du gros syndicat dominante
il ya des choses ou là les policiers
n'ont pas la même attitude et on le voit
dans un hymne dans nos hémicycle
défendre ces idées là d'une agriculture
paysanne deux territoires liés à la
saison eh bien elle elle a du mal
et comme il le disait tout à l'heure ça
va encore être des pertes d'emploi
paysans au moment où il faudrait réussir
et irait irriguer la france d'une
agriculture paysanne pour re
territorialisée l'alimentation alors on
se bat là dessus nous politiquement ils
se battent sur le terrain dans leurs
champs pour vivre ou survivre
il est absolument anormal que les choses
n'avancent pas le président avait promis
des paiements pour services
environnementaux qui ne sont pas
intégrés à la pac donc c'est la
poursuite de la logique du modèle
agricole avec la complaisance du
gouvernement sous la pression de la
fnsea sur la pression des lobbys de
l'agroalimentaire et les firmes de
l'agrochimie à quel point on vous
craignez que la pac 1 n'êtes pas à la
préservation de l'emploi agricole et
bien les aides à l'hectare vont
poursuivre le l'intérêt de pour les
exploitations de s'agrandir encore le
mouvement est déjà lancé c'était dit
tout alors quinze mille paysans
disparaissent chaque année du paysage et
la logique se continue pour aller vers
une agriculture industrielle
il ya une véritable fracture dans le
monde agricole les paysans
ceux qui croient ce modèle agro
chimiques industriels et ceux qui
défendent une agriculture paysanne en
lien avec les territoires et en lien
avec une accumulation de qualité et de
proximité
alors toujours pas d'accord à bruxelles
sur la pac à discussion reporté au mois
de juin est ce que vous êtes satisfait
moitié de ce délai supplémentaire pour
le moment toujours inquiet ceux qui ne
sont pas d'accord pour certains trouvent
que ça va encore trop déjà trop loin
pour l'environnement donc il ya un
véritable enjeu pour la france il il va
y avoir une nouvelle manifestation le 2
juin à l'appel de la fédération
nationale de l'agriculture biologique et
des ong qui défendent une autre pack j'y
serai présent avec d'autres élus on
espère qu'il y aura une forte
mobilisation
parce qu'on se rend compte que c'est par
le rapport de force que les choses pour
avancer et je le dis à chaque fois un
rapport de force qui soit pacifique
absolument pacifiques et non-violents
jouanno l'avait merci en tout cas
d'avoir été avec mon je rappelle que
vous êtes
c'est un tort que vous avez participé à
la manifestation parisienne hier merci
en tout cas vous d'avoir être en direct
avec nous